hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast gene expression analysis using
3-prime RNA sequencing I am Judy
Oracle's lab rats and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth and
sponsored by Lexington Lexington is a
transcriptomics and next-generation
sequencing company focusing on
development of products enabling
complete transcriptome sequencing for
more information please visit lexington
comm we have a few important now before
we begin this webcast is designed to the
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CTE
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Benham a bashed assistant
professor at the University of Delaware
venema wash'd joined the University of
Delaware's faculty as an assistant
professor in 2011 he received his PhD in
quantitative and molecular genetics in
France from inaugural campus
Rennes in 2006 he then completed a
postdoctoral fellowship in quantitative
genetics at Iowa State University
dr. Abbas was a research geneticist and
genomics project leader at Purdue farms
from 2008 until his appointment at the
University of Delaware this area of
research is integrative avian biology
with emphasis on fine mapping and
functional characterization of
quantitative trait loci QTL and chicken
I will now turn it over to dr. Abbas
okay thank you the moderator I my name
is Mohammad Bosch but more good morning
everyone my presentation is about gene
expression analysis using 3-prime RNA
sequencing so I first things I would
like to discuss is about the sample size
in RNA chikki studies most of the RNA
ticket studies as sample size of 6 to 12
biological replicates and typically be
compared for example affected samples
affected by disease versus unaffected or
we compare group a versus group B and
usually the sample fight is not so big
it's like a 6 to 12 biological replicate
and the cost per sample is about 400 to
500 dollars and we have done several or
initiative studies in the past these are
some examples of recent publication that
my lab conducted recently and this is
the major actually driving force to all
see how we can do what we can to reduce
the cost of RNA sequencing so in then we
need large number of samples to be
sequence for example then we do
population level studies of gene
expression and who those of you who are
familiar in each detail in each Intel
analysis we need to have maybe 500 600
sometimes thousands of samples so the
question was how we could do RNA taking
large number of the samples and whether
we can reduce the cost to $50.00 per
sample so I would let first the target I
talked about like RNA shake a convention
on RNA seek method so those of you who
are familiar you know that the first
isolate mRNA purified
money and then after purifying mRNA the
synthesized cDNA using protocols that
which are provided by by the company and
this cDNA cDNA library are are used to
make him small fragments of DNA it's
generally called
cDNA libraries so for the cDNA libraries
they sent them to sequencing after
sequencing people receive a large amount
of data like a small sequence read by an
example of sequence being Greece that
you receive in and after sequencing this
sample so there's going to be a hundred
or 50 base pair depends on the protocol
that you use you can generate a small
big small sequencing ways after that
after sequencing all these samples you
are you need to map them back to
reference genome modern most species of
interest a reference genome available so
we can map these frequency to the
reference genome and based on the number
of the reset map to their to the to each
gene you can quantify how much of that
gene is expressed so this is a like
typical or any chick experiment which is
used with bios and most laps who are
studying RNA RNA sequencing so into it
down in the following slides i will
compare rnaseq conventional methods with
three prime RNA state so in the bottom
here you see there is a gene model we
have on the left here we have five prime
UTR utr stands for youth untranslated
region and in on the side on the left
side left hand side we have five prime
UTR on the right hand side we have three
prime UTR and in the middle we have
coding sequence so this is a structure
of gene in gene model so when you are
talking about RNA tick and all in a
degree basically sequence all the
transcripts produce from the gene so the
full transcript we the goal is to
sequence a transcript and it is
basically taking everything and
sequencing in the transcript but if you
compare all in a6 with three prime three
prime are in ethic so here you can see
that in three prime automatic we don't
sequence full transcript but we focus on
the right hand side is you can take
treat three prime three prime UTR we
only frequency a hundred base pair from
three prime UTR and we use this
information to quantify gene expression
so if we count all these transcript one
by one so we could we could quantify
expression of the gene so if the goal is
to measure gene expression we don't have
to sequence full transcript and people
do in RNA second also so for
quantification proposed we only need to
sequence a small part of each transcript
which the three prime RNA sequencing we
can do that we can just confine
sequencing to the end of the transcript
so this will from here it is up with
that how much saving will be because we
we don't need we wouldn't use all the
material sequencing material so sequence
for full transcript we would just
sequence a small fragment of each
transcript so if you consider for
example this one is when this figure
shows distribution of transcript length
it is in chicken I am because I am
studying and my studies are on most of
it we are studying chickens so I took
all genes from our latest and actually
this is not the latest one that they
one just published this is gal gal four
which is the version before the recent
fun written one just updated a few
months ago so we took all the transcript
and look at the length and distribution
of the lens and you can see some
transcript is as big as 26 K P so
there's transcript it big size and and
average the transcript length is 2008
Spears so now you are comparing
sequencing 2000 base pair instead of
sequencing 100 base pair instead of 2008
there so you can see how much saving
will be if we can we can just focus on
horse on a small piece of it RNA so this
was basically it shows that how the
difference between three prime and a
tree farm or annuity and conventional
RNA stick method another benefits
besides cost saving there are other
benefits of three prime RNA analysis one
of them is to detect alternative
polyadenylation poly elimination we know
that from basic and biology it's every
time in eukaryotes RNA is transcribed
and transcribe 2 and RNA is transcribed
from gene at first at earlier stage they
are pre mRNA they are called pre mRNA
which stands for pre mature mRNA so
there are couple of things happened
before pre mRNA became mature mRNA one
of them is basically including the site
including the tape of the transcript the
here as you can see here there is a
cleavage site this site is determined
based on this consensus sequence here
wherever this consensus sequence is
about 11 to 30 base pairs on in this
transcript will be cleaved
and after cleavage we're going to have
shorter transcript and if you were like
that you can see here this part is the
part but screen then the transcript is
shorter than the previous type and after
this info at final stage if probably a
cake as you can see here poly 88 is
added to the transcript so this is a
that it basically happens for old
messenger RNA that are transcribed from
genes in eukaryotes so we're going to
have we're going to have first them
premature and dead mature RNA and there
is quite amount of variation in terms of
where this transcript will be cleaved it
could be in different size and this
alternative cleavage produce a variation
in the transcript length at 3 prime UTR
region so some transcript can be from
the same genes it could be a transcript
with a longer
utr region it could be a transcript with
shorter through 3 prime UTR region so
there's going to be variation in the
transcript plant based on the fact that
where this cleavage will be happen and
this has implication because some of the
some of the men RNAs financing
mechanisms is related to for example if
I RNA or micro RNA and these molecules
mostly attached to 3 prime UTR of the
mRNA molecule that they control so it is
extremely important to know exactly how
big is the transcript and it is 3 prime
UTR region so if we don't use means we
know this information we can we can
understand the authority's mechanism
Hobday for example one transcript could
be financed with fi RNA or mRNA so these
are where this is another benefit of
three prime RNA sequencing and here i
will present you the experimental design
that
youth we basically took the adipose
tissue from chickens the isolated or in
a sample and then we had overall 61
samples 20 samples was using for both
rnaseq and 3-prime automated but 41
samples we had only used for three prime
RNA sequencing
so after sequencing so in the put in
this case we have 20 samples which has
both or anything and three plant or
native this will allow us to compare
these two technology to see if we can
achieve high accuracy with three prime
RNA sequencing so we did that typically
we do in lab after RNA sequencing we
check the quality of RNA using a pyro
monitor to make sure that the RNA has
high quality we use RNA that has an
eight or higher than eight integrity
value so after quality check we follow
the three prime or analytic library
preparation step so these this is the
protocol you can find more detail about
the protocols in mold it's all
publishing nature methods so I will
don't go through details of the protocol
but I would like just emphasize here
this party in first step that we the
primers that are used to amplify or
synthesize cDNA they have a
complimentary T which attach to poly a
tail of mRNA so you have a poly a tail
and the primer would be it would have
poly 88 a poly TK so it would be
complimentary to probably eight eight of
the mRNA so we will back to this point
again because this is an important
things to consider in our analysis and
you will see what where where this is
important
so after synthesizing on cDNA library
they are sequence and also these are
more information about how the
sequencing can be done
you can find from this paper in mold at
all so I will go to mostly my talk will
be top the analyze this data after
sequencing so we firstly check the
quality of libraries dishes before
sequencing actually which is also
important point to consider because the
amount of cDNA is much lower than what
you get from conventional RNA stick
method so you need to use high gain high
sensitivity DNA essay so these are if
you use them typical on DNA I say it
would not be detected but you have you
should use high sensitivity DNA essay
and we check all their cDNA libraries
that we generated to make sure that they
have high quality and they should be
should be freedoms and product in
product when you do this RNA DNA you're
going to see the product in and which is
which is indicating there's enough
amount of material for sequencing and
then we follow this protocol for DNA
data processing so we took 61 samples
from abdominal fat we did local
alignment mode using bowtie - and the
dis we got 90 percent of the reads map
to the chicken reference genome which is
total number of reads will be 1 123
million breathe after this we went to
the second step with quality controls in
quality control we looked at the be
excluded all these high low quality
mapping with the reach that has more low
quality for example did the criteria
that yields was less than 10 and after
that the excluded repetitive repetitive
sequence or sequence with poly a stretch
B I will come back to this point later
on and so this was one of the criteria
we used to exclude
hope is repetitive sequence and poly a
stretch and after we and before we end
up with fixing 36 percent of the reads
which was 49 million reads and in next
step we detected the position of three
prime UTR it is basically one of the
advantage of the technology that I
mentioned it allows to detect three
prime UTR and then be identified
alternative polyadenylation and i will
talk about this later and netten final
step was using HTC hd2 is a software for
quantification of gene expression we use
HT 6 to chance to quantify transcript
amount of transcript from each gene and
in each sample and then we because I as
I mentioned we had both rnaseq and 3
prime RNA seek data we use these two two
data set to compare a whether we have
high accuracy it is actually comparable
between RNA fake and three prime
coronated so we had for this amongst us
we had and ten high and ten low P
efficiency chickens this has been
studied before Papa's paper published in
that we compared high feed efficiency
with low key deficiency chickens so we
use the same data set to also compute
the same thing with three prime RNA
sequencing and to find out how high is
the correlation between these two
technology and I'm now going to the some
of the challenges that we faced when we
were trying to analyze data process data
so one of the challenges is basically
what you see here we have an intron and
this is an exon here and this is a
depart with a solid box but but cleaner
than the other solid box
it's called it is three prime UTR region
so this is gene model in
current gene annotation file showing
that transferred the gene model ends in
this point here but when we mapped our
three prime RNA seek data this is v r
actuals three prime RNA seek data and
then be mapped is three prime or an
insulator these are our sequencer e
shown from 3 prime authentic all all of
them was almost all of them map to this
region so we see that this region is
much farther than where transcript and
transcript and you can see here
transcript ends a much shorter but
obviously this gene model is should and
shouldn't be quick and should be
extended to cover larger region so to
fix this problem and be decided to
basically we use a prop parameter to
extend all genes up to 5 KB and if we
find it tasks be found in location
within this 5 KB that our reads map to
be considered that as in legitimate and
3 prime end of the gene so we will have
more examples in not following this
import following slide where so this
parameter we improve some gene models
and but still we had some other issues
so it is an opposite example so I forget
to mention in previous slide you could
also see automatic because we had both a
3 prime RNA stick and ordinances beta in
Oran ASIC this is consistently we can
see that all native data also shows that
there is a chair lots of reads mapping
to this area but there's nothing in gene
model showing that is whether there is a
gene or there is not AG it shows that
there is no gene here but obviously this
reads all RNA secrets belongs to the
genes that but in this here
so this edition need to be extended
further because the both automatic and
3-prime monistic shows that there are
there are expression in this area so
going back to the continuing with our
example that is opposite to the example
that I showed so become at here we have
a three prong or any three prime UTR
that ends here in this case gene
direction is from here and jinx
Direction is from right to left it is in
minus strand so we we don't see any
sequencing reads mapping to the end of
the transcript because our three prime
RNA dictators should map to the end of
the transcript but we don't see any
reads mapping to the end of transcript
but we see most of the reads our
automated state are mapped to this
region and a little bit of them like a
few sequence and map here but most of
them match to the previous as I
indicated here this region
so obviously this gene model would also
be wrong it needs to be shortened it is
opposite of what we just talked about it
this this genes is in database it is
longer than its supposed to be so we
also fix this problem by just basically
finding out where is the end of the
transcript and cutting that and reducing
to the smaller of transcript so screen
this is another problem and B when we
were looking to gene model you can see
there's a intron here is X on here
there's another intron here and in our
three prime or any thick data we found
that some breeds like you can see get
these reads or mapping to exons and also
these rates are mapping to excels this
exon is within the gene so it is
unexpected to see this big greets or
naughty to takes on within an exam in
individual of gene so we will we will
curious about what what
is going on here so what we did we just
zoomed in to see what what happened like
like intently to region here and what we
found out after zooming in these are the
stretch of poly a you can see here we
have a also one for a year and two A's
here a year and there's more aid here
which basically comes from the fact that
the technology because as you remember
from my previous slide when we try to
imply mRNA we use primer with poly a
cave which attach to poly a tail of the
mRNA but that probably a tail is added
after transcription but it is not poly a
tail that are within the gene but here
we have a a stretch which is within the
gene it is in it is coming from DNA it
is not that for the 18 that was added
after transcription so then whenever we
have this situation the genes and the
transcript downstream of that and
upstream of that will be basically of
end up in our cDNA library so we have to
come up with a parameter to delete all
these threes because these are not real
end of the transcript the reason that VT
that reads here because oxygen upstream
of this really be there's poly eighty
stretch so to fix this problem we what
we did we for the look though all these
transcript for example with then
deformed location that our only three
prime RNA seek data map in this location
we consider the endpoint here from
endpoint the the com- pain them to
toward left and minus - plus 18 towards
right and but in this region 10 - ten
plus
which is 28 base pair we looked to find
if there is in 12 days in exciting
windows of 18 days pick so one of the
cry this was one of the criteria 12s in
sliding windows of 18 base pair or we
were looking to see if there is eight
consecutive AIDS
so the become up this parameter after
fine-tuning after trying different
things and also by consulting with lakes
which in Lexington is a company that is
providing this kit and they had more
experience on how to handle this data
and the after consulting with the
company and also find to maybe we come
up with this criteria so now applying
these criteria we basically removed
eliminated
lots of reads that was smacking to this
kind of region so we we had also another
issue size you can see here we have in
left left side we have gene a which is
in positive strand and the right side we
have a other other gene gene be in minus
strand so in gene a the direction that
is going is from left to right and gene
be going from right to left so these are
in because they are in opposite strand
so the question was because you can see
all these read between gene a and gene B
and it was not clear where this patrice
belong to are they belong to all these
reads we can't dishes are amazing based
on ordinances so whether this all these
reads in RNA sigmak to gene a or they
belong to gene a or they are belong to
gene B so based on RNA seek data is not
clear where they should want to but we
use a three term RNA seek data to figure
out where they belong to you can see
here we have three prime RNA seek data
and it is not very clear in this slide
but these three type direction it shows
that resolve going to this direction so
this obviously all the transcript that
is nothing here belongs to Jean B but
Jean B starts here and but this in G
model this region belongs to Jean 8 so
if you use automatically we're going to
count all these transcript to Jean a but
actually these rates belong to Jean be
so we can separate these two genes here
B gene a gene B will be from here but
because it in here we have low
expression of gene a we can really
determine with high confidence where
gene a start
we can just say a gene beat starts here
but based on the data that we have from
adipose tissue this genes doesn't
express much in adipose tissue so we
need to look at another tissue to see
where they studied this genes expressed
hired so we're going to look at another
example that both genes are expressing
higher for example in this case we have
gene the same scenario but both genes
are experiencing higher we have gene a
in pluses Chan and gene be in minus
strand and we also have all these reads
in this area and we don't because it's
transcripts and for gene BMC a
transcript for gene a and here this is
based on current gene model annotation
so we don't this doesn't really because
we see all these reads between two genes
based on RNA take we can't we can't tell
where they belong to so we do after
using 3 prime RNA 6 we have 3 prime or
Natick here so you chose that these all
these reads of balaam switching a long
gene B because the reads are this list
you can select the sequence read from or
Natick 3 prime or NSTIC it's marking
here
and we can determine well if Jaden start
so obviously the model gene B has the
correct model because transcript a
starts from the our reads are mapping to
the point that this transcript ends so
we can we can basically be confident
that gene B has correct model but gene a
has gene a has the gene model is for
gene the gene a is not quick and other
things that we can pick up from this
picture we can see alter there is
multiple sides that our three prime RNA
seek data is mapping and this is where
what I mentioned in the previous slide
that some genes has multiple cleavage
wise and there's multiple poly
elimination so using three prime RNA
stick we can also determine its
multiples probably elimination sites so
it is just the same slide but zoomed in
you can see that the breat hat direction
the this reads going to from right to
left these rates going from left to
right so we can say that which which
means they are belong to so this is
another case for one of the problems
that which all is based on gene model
you can see this is these are two exons
and and this is an intron but we we saw
in both in our music and three primary
matrix there are lots of reads mapping
to intron so obviously this would be not
this part would not be an intron this
looks like a three prime UTR
and just started after this exam here
right here so all the transcript after
this exons should should be like a
extension of three prime UTR region of
this exam so this this is another case
that B we fix it with parameters that
used for data analysis and this is a
also
interesting things that you can see how
many alternative sites for poly
elimination exists in the transcript and
we are looking to three prime or native
in 61 samples pull together and also
three prime RNA ticks but this time
looking one single sample and on here we
have RNA seek data so based on this
graph we can see even in one single
samples there are multiple sides of poly
indignation part of it can be because of
alternative splicing and part of it it
could be because of usage of the three
prime UTR so this with three prime UTR
we could also figure out the alternative
polyadenylation size in in the
transcripts in the genes
so after is doing all these improvement
and the current filtering the data
cleaning this for example looking for
the eighth stage and extending three
prime UTR
we were wrongly how good we were doing
so we looked at these are as you
remember from earlier stars there's a
poly ordination signals these are
typical known polyadenylation signal
signals which is called
consensus sequence so this as you can
like the first one is the most frequent
one in in mammalian and also in birds as
we can see here in chickens also if this
is the most most abundant
polyadenylation signal based on current
adamant and current annotation it is
which is showing by blue the color is
poodle for the current gene model the
color is bred for our improved
annotations so our improved annotation
defined in two times more of these as
signals in india in the transcript so it
shows that the improvement we did is
actually improve the gene model
annotation because you can
default is almost more than double the
number of poly elimination signal and
the second second month also it is
doubled so the digit the second second
non poly ordination signal so we can see
that there's also two time increase in
this signal in our transcript and
overall if we put all together here we
have percentage of transcript with at
least one consensus sequence in current
gene model annotation that only 64 point
25 percent of Sigma transcript with the
non polyadenylation signal but then we
use our improved annotation we found
that ninety one point eight percent of
the transcript has at least one
consensus sequence and if you go to this
category percentage of chances with two
most abundant most common and poly
elimination signals which is a a you AAA
and a usual AAA so in based on current
gene model annotation there's thirty
nine point four two percent and based on
our improved model is eighty four eighty
point seventy six percent so this
clearly shows that using our improved
annotation gene annotation it could help
to identify this more of these poly
ordination sites and is it things that
needed a criteria that we use it helps
to improve the G model so in this part
of my presentation I will actually talk
about the differential expression
analysis because we had both automatic
and three primary basic data we can
compare RNA 63 prime rnaseq we had from
RNA take we found out to 217 cygnets
significant EE genes differentially
expressed genes between 10 high peak
efficiency and 10 go feed efficiency
broilers these are mid type chickens so
total number of reads from rnaseq we had
60 million read
sample which puts like done in based on
four four samples early and in three
program RNA seek data we had two million
per sample you can see sixty million
versus two million so there's big
difference between on the number of
reads per sample so this was done all 61
samples but we're pooled and sequence on
one plane so the results was really
ensures high improvement and be used
improve annotation so in current model
the correlation is is point seven eight
two correlation between rnaseq log two
fold change and log two fold change
three prime rnaseq so that we had
correlation displeased of this
correlation within to technology so
correlation point seven eight
compared to correlation point seven
point nine one which shows old
improvement that we did for gene model
using three prime RNA seek data help us
to have two to reach to high accuracy
but even with this point nine one six we
think there is room for improvement
because there are other problems that
for example here we we have be having to
still fix this problem we are working on
fixing these these problems we have here
- Jim model ends here but there are
women exons missing from gene model so
if the dishes indicated both and based
on our basic and 3-prime automatic and
if you presume in beginning to see that
our three prime or they dictate our
mapping to here so the distance
basically need to be extended ordered
but we haven't extended this gene if we
fix this type this type of problem we
may still improve our correlation
another problem was as you remember we
also use the criteria to remove
repetitive sequence and that sometimes
because end of the transcriptase there
are repetitive sequencing at the end of
the transcript
then we use it app this is like default
QC and this is after QC before QC means
we didn't remove repetitive sequence
after to see bu remove the repetitive
sequence so once we did QC and then all
the reads that were mapped before to
this location this is three prime RNA
degrade
so all these threes are eliminated so
this is one of the problem that we are
trying to fix them
we have repetitive sequence at the end
of the transcript another example there
is also called couple cause I think I
have I am doing in terms of time how
much time by I live moderated here
you're fine to go on as long as you wish
you should change for me okay okay thank
you so yeah there is a couple others
like problem we can see here there is a
gene which basically it is within
another disc genes and here but based on
our RNA stick and three prime RNA seek
data the gene which gene should be
extended up to here and B but we have we
have another gene which I actually
showed here it is within this gene so we
currently still take this problem how we
address this type of problem and another
problem located at do you remember I
mentioned the extended genes up to 5 KB
but sometimes we we find a breach
mapping to even farther than type KB we
we are still trying to solve this
problem so even some of the reads
mapping to even party there part KB so
at the end I would like to just conclude
gives a few conclusion as you see we
haven't still finish all that all the
way down but we I feel that we are
confident to make some conclusion
translation study we have first of all
it's going to be big cost saving if the
goal is just to count for a gene
expression we can make some cost saving
here
it has this network is required like
very low amount of sequencing so there's
only is cost saving and this helps you
to scale up sequencing projects to use
that sequencing for population studies
and also the 3-prime modernistic as i
mentioned it allows for accurate
detection of the three prime end of the
transcript which enables verification of
the current gene modern annotation based
on this date this data theory annotated
8150 cm and gene from out of ten
thousand six hundred ninety three genes
these are ten thousand genes is the
number of genes had expressed in adipose
tissue based on our data so basically we
could be reallocated seventy six percent
of the gene and and we also we were able
to characterize alternative for the
elimination side and that means we had
find that
7350 for gene had a alternative
polyadenylation size which is a few
considers ten thousand six hundred
ninety three genes that are expressed in
adipose tissue this will be almost seven
seventy percent of the genes so 70
percent of the gene shows alternative
polyadenylation which is huge amount of
variation people would be interested in
looking association between variation in
polyadenylation and phenotype so it's at
some time transcript with different
lands they do different job or they have
different time and light and long life
life on so it would be interesting it so
could people study at the type of m poly
automation using the technology that is
not very expensive so i paint i would
like to thank people who actually cook
helped me to do this project basically
we had multiple most of it quite for 9.4
magic analysis from a vision to grad
student in my lab and usual and most
they did a library preparation so they
basically did most of the work
so I thank them for their collaboration
and also their financial supports that
University of Delaware provided and also
tanks a company Lexington for for the
kids and if there is any question at
this point I would be happy to take
thank you dr. abashed at this point I
would like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to get
to as many questions as we can and your
first question is where can i buy the
kit is Lexington the producer of this
kit yes they produce this kid like we
bought from Mexican so there and they
have they I and I saw them in that year
in addition and pH either you still
continue selling this kit by removing
internal climbing events associated with
the oligo DT priming of reverse
transcription yeah that's what that was
actually one of the issues we couldn't
eliminate at at that point but we do buy
automatically as I actually explained
the user criteria to eliminate reads but
we that happens the internal priming
happens they generate some problems but
we could remove them using by automatics
what is the role of the poly a tail at
the three prime ends of mRNA yeah that's
a good question they basically poly a
Cade has several roles one of them is
stabilizing on RNA so it poly 88 if it
is a shorter DNA have a less latinum
should relieve lot shorter but it is
longer the I'm sorry already or enable
leave mono
so there are multiple rules for poly 88
in the end of transcript
the most common the most important one
is that the top soon RNA will be
degraded depends on the length of the
poly 80 can we detect alternative
splicing using this method yes yes I
actually talked a little so yeah you can
you can do it because it's this target
the end of the transcript if you have
one gene with multiple alternative
polyadenylation size you could be able
to find reads mapping to that site how
many reads per sample are in your
opinion appropriate or suggestion for
Kwan sheet analysis so to be used in
this study we had two million which
provided the decent results so I think
two minions but I would also recommend
to check with the company to say that is
they have another recommendation based
on our results 2 million reads per
sample is is provide satisfactory result
if you compare RNA sick with three prime
rnaseq it gives you 49 for 49 one
correlation which is the III think that
is it a good good correlation between
the independent technology what we doing
has been imaged for sequencing we used
100 base pair a single end but my
recommendation to going forward is will
be two paired end same size of the read
length so it's haunted place there but
paired end reads will be better than
single end reads because sometimes like
one of the problem that I mentioned
repetitive sequence so if one of the one
of the pairs mapped to repetitive
sequence you can also use another pair
so it could probably reduce those
problem so we plan to use piers and
sequencing later on this was single and
but future project we would like to use
paid in but humble base pair in terms of
length of each a trade it would be good
you isolate polyadenylated RNAs before
carrying the library is using an oligo
DT sorry I'm missing out you know it is
there basically it is that does it
doesn't have that stage it because
you're using primers that amplifies it
and that Pat and targets poly a tail so
this protocol if I'm not quick if I'm
not wrong this protocol doesn't have
this mRNA purification stage it's just
use a total RNA to start this what is
the napping quality mapping quality was
good we lost 10% of the wreath after
cheesy formatting mapping quality so
this is like it even higher than what
you can get on it with RNA 6 ohm as I
deposit based on our data mapping
quality buzz good
why you remove reads with poly a stretch
wouldn't training be better in tree
because those poly dreaming wouldn't
solve because those reads me to be
eliminated because poly a stretch is not
representing the end of the transcript
they are within the transcript so if you
will if your goal is to detect poly
automation it will give you false
positive results because you're going to
see reads are mapping to the location
with poly a stretch which is hopefully
identified added poly elimination side
this would be a problem for detecting
poly automation side but if the goal is
to quantify gene expression you don't
need to remove those rates because if
you have two groups let's say group
treatment group versus control group and
both of them gonna have the same and
because both of them going to have
reads mapping to poly the region bit
poly eight stretch so when you compare
two genes and see two
launches into group both groups going to
be roughly equally as affected so for
now answer will be you need to remove
those poly a stretch when the goal is to
identify for the elimination but you
don't need to remove them then the goal
is just to quantify gene expression
while extending the utr how do you
handle the fact that there may be other
genes in a 5k be window that's that
that's a good question
so we put another criteria that then
that fight 5k extension hits another
gene so it's tough that there is top
before moving in inside that audition so
we extend it as long as there's no other
genes in the downstream when you find
this word wrong is in quotes when you
find wrong three prime ends upstream or
downstream the annotated three prime
ends isn't it possible that it is
actually alternative poly a site
specific to your cell type or it's the
condition tested allowing the existence
of the equals wrong annotated three
prime ends in another condition and that
was the question number can you police
the ice floe 12 can you see that Oh
Carol would you want me to read it again
yeah I I see Dave okay give me a few
seconds just only to okay it's a lot I
don't see end of the questions like in
here oh okay I'll look below look um so
you'll see the top if you want my lane
number 12 look below near the end of the
page the hole okay
yes yes that's a very good question
and I read yes that it could be it could
be that G model is based on one one
specific tissue or cell type but we
found it with a pond and another side
which comes from the tissue that we use
so that is really a good question that's
why we have to have multiple pieces if
you want to create a gene model need to
be multiple pieces so if I'm working in
one tissue so I would be confident that
the gene model also covered there my
gene in but yet that's that's that's
possible the this technology need to be
applied across many or more teachers to
be able to provide a model that will
work with every teacher what is the
frequency of transcript in which you
don't have three prime UTR students
compared to RNA seek what is the
frequency of the trial image and English
they don't have three prime UTR even
future sequence compares RNA shake oh
you want to take that one later
okay so let me three per page Oh all
these transcript mRNA transcript they
need to have three prime UTR sequence so
I be having look at this to come up with
a good number so I we haven't done this
analysis yet okay um any idea how many
genes if any have the same three prime
sequence and can therefore cannot be
distinguished from the data on same
three times difference yep we didn't
find this this type of big maybe
maybe in some species that has better
gene annotations men for example humans
and there will be many genes with the
same three prime sequence but in
chickens we are still not we don't have
that quality of the that quality of the
annotation part so we don't see many
genes utilizing saying 3 5 utr how much
do you clip off the reads before
aligning we don't we don't really we
don't clip any any up very big because
we put the Equality parameter if the
Equality is more the reads will won't
map so we didn't clip any any actually
any anything how much total RNA do you
use to begin with and total RNA that I
don't remember but they are indicated in
the protocols how much we followed it
for what how much their RNA and was
recommended based on the protocol doctor
- do you have time to answer a few more
questions you have yes ok so the next
one is where can I find a full
description of the methods used to
correct gene models and overall
Corrections for the issues with reprime
RNA feed described in the seminar ah the
habit is to publish data I would be
happy to help if there is any question
if someone wants to know bit about
details but it still there's this study
we haven't published it there is no like
information published available okay we
have someone else's just thank you
several other people have also just
written in thanks for your presentation
here's another one how about alternative
splicing transcripts that skipped some
middle exon because we are looking to
the end of the transcript so we wouldn't
they take the old those that are skip
the middle like songs so
we will see that transcript there is
more so the people that would require
other other things because we don't
really looking for all that is
alternative transcripts and that is
generated based on or splicing what
instrument is used for the gene
expression analysis and for analytical
expense please gene expression analysis
HT 6 a software is called HT sick in
question asking the method of
quantification it will be HT thick and I
have may have missed this as I joined
late when you make the library how do
you check their quality before
proceeding to sequencing yes they be
used by analyzer by analyzer but also I
emphasize that we use high sensitivity
kit because the amount of see any degree
is as or so we have you you have to use
a high sensitivity sensitivity kit so
the answer will be bioanalyzer using
high sensitivity if there in litigation
are you going to read also question
number I can follow like each question
yes oh of course the next one is 22 you
and the question is is there any
limitation to using fresh samples versus
fixed tissue samples how much of an RNA
extraction amount is needed the haven't
tried this fixed sample they use fresh
sample all the time so I would refer to
this question to be asked on the company
so how much mRNA extraction will be
started with minimum amount of RNA
extraction that we had in the 3 nano
grams per microliter but I think it is
but I don't think exactly remember how
much we put we used it and recommended
amount that recommended by the protocol
okay now around 23
to me please elaborate on the
methodological usage of 3-prime RNA
sequencing with RNA silencing and so
they could because their distance just
have been then in RNA financing those
small RNA like si RNA micro RNA they
attach to most of them attached to three
prime UTR
so this is going to kind of view you
when you find some transitive has larger
three prime UTR compared to a shorter
bond and if if you have a micro RNA that
attached to a three prime UTR region so
if you don't have any impact on the
transcript which shorter the mRNA
mapping to this region that is not
present in your transcript so you
shouldn't be worried about it impact of
that micro RNA on your transcript so
this is kind of like if you could you
couldn't do actually you couldn't do any
experiment to validate it but you can
hypothesize that for example if I have a
my a transcript that is shorter they had
shorter to you three prime UTR
and there there is no site for micro RNA
in to attach to that transcript so there
is less likelihood for for the
transcript to be impacted with micro RNA
in our on 24 how can three prime RNA
seek how can a 3 or a 3 prime RNA seek
approach is helpful in polyploidy models
polyploidy of I have to think I don't
know I do not right now obvious to me
how it could be helpful because Polly
you're going to have a part in
polyploidy supposedly they're going but
there's going to be more more up the
transcript some same gene so if there is
a if there is a variation on gene
expiration that arise from polyploidy
for example one chromosomes and
transcript which is different from other
chromosome producing the same transcript
so if there is a variation at chromosome
levels it could be helpful and to point
pinpoint for example in your system if
you have if tetraploid e and genes will
have four copies of the gene and each
copy may utilize different alternatives
for the automation side so it could help
but we we never try to see how it could
be because there's the we just look at a
system that was diploid number 25 is how
can we select the gene not sure what the
question and help the detail at the gene
because we don't select any genes we are
basically looking all the genes because
we are studying like RNA cause in RNA
take you sequence all the olden mRNA in
the sample the same thing here
you're basically sequencing three prime
UTR of all the transcripts in europe in
your sample number 26 is what was the
significance of the complimentary poly
t-tail because we talked about the used
primary that had poly teeth and to
attach to poly a so this also can attach
to the region of the genome that has
poly a stretch and produce false
positive so that's why we wanted to
remove those sites to not have poly and
false positives so you if the question
is talking about and the issues that
caused it poly 8 and poly a stretch so
we only the way that we can solve it is
using a bioinformatics it is three prime
RNA sequencing applicable with
cytoplasmic neutron retention mRNAs
okay at Number twenty eleven I I'm not
very familiar with the cytoplasmic
intron retention by mRNA it looks and
sounds to me some based on this question
it looks like from in cytoplasmic and
mRNA some time RNA an intron is retained
at the exam but I don't think that would
be helpful because if intron is retained
within the gene you couldn't be able to
detect the three prime or anything but
it's like yes I think it is not going to
be helpful if intron retain and because
in the last things that we have is exons
so the technology targeting the exon
last exam so if you have an intron
retain it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
detected based on three prime RNA
sequencing thank you I would once again
like to thank dr. venema bashed for his
presentation our exam is pronounced
ringing abashed for his presentation do
you have any final comments for us oh
not really
I protected tanks is everyone that and
and listen to this presentation if there
if there is any questions and if I can
help I would be happy just send me
emails I might we can find my contact
information from University of the
lovers website so if there is any
question that I can help please send me
me great thank you page I would also
like to thank our sponsor Alexa Jen for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
September 15 to 2016 receive an email
from lab roots alerting when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to fold that announcement to
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time
goodbye